[Music]
by the year 2035
nasa plans to send humans to mars
but it would be about a nine month trip
with our current rocket technology
however in the not so distant future
we could be replacing chemical engines
with nuclear thermal propulsion
that would take you to mars in just
three months
what are the risks of using nuclear
propulsion
how would it work and have we
ever used nuclear energy in space before
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we had nuclear powered rockets
nuclear propulsion would open up space
exploration but
there are some serious challenges that
we would have to overcome
first the nuclear engines would need to
be
safe and lightweight and that isn't
easy to achieve since they'd be
operating at a temperature of
2430 degrees
and this wouldn't be the first time we
would try using nuclear power
in space in 1958
project orion was a rocket design that
tested a nuclear propulsion system
and let me tell you it was bizarre
instead of using anything that resembles
our
current rocket engine project orion
used blast waves to propel the spaceship
forward
yeah you heard me blast waves
orion would eject small nuclear bombs
behind it
one at a time a few seconds later
boom the coffee can sized bomb detonated
plasma from the explosion would catch up
with
orion's back then hit a thick
shock absorbing plate this would protect
the ship from the radiation
and move it forward every time a bomb
detonated
the space vessel would gain speed
the idea was that by using this
technology
you could increase velocity so much that
you could reach any point in the solar
system
in one year but the idea of
casually detonating nuclear bombs in
space
didn't sit well with a public that
already feared nuclear power
so project orion was terminated fast
forward to today
and we have a new opportunity to use
nuclear power in space
but not by using bombs
which i'm pretty thankful for i don't
know about you but the idea of bombs
exploding in space
doesn't sound like a good long-term plan
to me
the only bombs i like are these ones
yeah i know they need a little work but
that's why i joined fitbot
fitbot has made it so much easier to
find the right exercises
pace and intensity for your workout and
that gives you better results because
it builds a fitness program that
constantly adapts to you
rocket ships aren't the only things that
need momentum so if you're looking for
some extra incentive
join fitbot today use our special coupon
code and get 25
off your membership you know i'm always
trying to understand
crazy new technology and mind exploding
science and
when i work out i don't want to have to
think too hard so i love how
easy this app's instructions are it
makes my workouts fun
gives my brain a break and i know that
i'm training safely because
fitbot makes sure that i don't overwork
any of my muscles and you know i'm a
video guy so
i appreciate that fitbot has hd videos
that make learning new exercises a
breeze
personalized training can be tough on
anyone's budget but
fitbot is only 9.99 a month or even
better
59.99 a year and if you sign up now
you'll get 25 percent off your
membership build the momentum to carry
your fitness journey
through the rest of the year with fitbit
get twenty five percent
off a membership when you sign up now at
fitbot.me
what if that's 25 off your membership
at fitbot.me what if
instead of using bombs to get to mars
we'd use
a nuclear thermal propulsion system with
a reactor core
this reactor core would be eight times
hotter than nuclear power plant cores
it would heat fuel in this case liquid
hydrogen
to 2430 degrees
turning it into a gas and creating
thrust
right now the nuclear thermal propulsion
system would use
fission to heat the reactor core fission
splits a larger atom usually uranium
into at least two smaller atoms
but in the future when we've got the
right technology
we could use fusion instead fusion is
the opposite of fission
it would join at least two smaller atoms
into a bigger one releasing up to four
times more energy than fission
that would be one energetic rocket
wow that's very impressive and
a quicker space trip wouldn't just be
convenient it would
also be safer for the crew astronauts
are exposed to cosmic radiation when
they're in space
which can cause serious long-term health
issues
radiation shielding could help but it's
extremely heavy
and the longer the mission the more
shielding you'd need
so by reducing your time spent in space
you'd limit the crew's health risks and
the mission would cost less and
we'd use these rockets for more than
transportation
once a rocket has reached its
destination
the nuclear reactor could switch from a
propulsion system
to a power source so
what are the drawbacks to nuclear
thermal propulsion
well you could only use this system when
the vessel is in space
it would still need chemical thrusters
to leave earth
there could be a lot of radiation
effects so the farther away from
earth's atmosphere it is before the ntp
systems switch on
the better and the word nuclear
sets off a lot of alarm bells we'd be
dealing with
explosive radioactive material after all
but the nuclear propulsion system would
be designed so that
even if there were a launch failure
only a minimum amount of uranium would
disperse
reducing any radioactive spills
scientists have studied this type of
engine since the late 1950s but
it hasn't flown in space yet regulations
and
lack of funding have slowed its
development
but in 2019 nasa
received 100 million dollars to
develop nuclear thermal propulsion
making their
2035 plan of sending humans to mars
much more achievable nuclear energy
could be the future of space exploration
now what if we used it on earth
as our only fuel source
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you